houses for you
[Music]
I'm a special Masters edition of the
dish we head south Southeast from
Augusta Georgia to Savannah and The Old
Pink House the restaurant like the
Masters itself and even the city it sits
in is Rich with history and tradition
and while the building itself has served
as everything from a church to a bank
over the last 250 years as a restaurant
it's reached back to its original
purpose serving as a home for
inspiration helping The Old Pink House
provide its customers with more than
just a meal
[Music]
Savannah Georgia best known for its
Southern Charm and hospitality
[Music]
one place that embodies it all nestled
in the historic district is The Old Pink
House
first time at The Old Pink House awesome
that you're here Craig Jeffress has
served as general manager for 13 years
the colonial Mansion turned restaurant
has become a dining destination with the
home itself as much of a draw as the
food wow and Welcome to our grand
ballroom oh this is amazing so a grand
ballroom back in the day yes just
another one of the great rooms inside
this home that we invite friends over
every night to have dinner the first
thing people usually notice when they
come in of course is the chandeliers and
the Sparkle and then they of course
notice the scenery in the hand-painted
wallpaper here well the original home
had just five rooms the restaurant is
made up of 13 unique dining spaces which
room is this welcome to the master
bedroom from 1771 in the opening house
built by James Habersham Jr a colonial
Merchant the building's one constant in
its 252-year history has been the
unmistakable pink exterior due to its
original red clay bricks the wife of
Habersham junior said all the wealthy
people in town their homes are stucco
please cover our home stucco so as a
good husband he covered his home in
Stucco what they didn't understand is
that everything in south Georgia sweats
in the summertime including the ray clay
bricks right so they're gorgeous stucco
home turned pink over and over and over
again it's in the home now don't fight
it don't fight it it won't work out for
you
inside the culinary offerings live up to
The Old Pink House distinction and this
smells amazing in both taste and
presentation we started our lunch with a
simple but iconic offering cheese straws
they are made by hand every day really
happy to get that reaction as you just
had love to hear that snap and it just
has the right amount of flavors and
season to it as did everything we tried
from signature Southern dishes Savannah
is known for like shrimp and grits we
make a tassel ham gravy and then of
course it's not complete without those
tender sweet Georgia white shrimp it's
like this giant hash brown oh yes that's
what I kept thinking to items that add a
modern twist a roasted sweet potato with
pecan vanilla butter and The BLT salad
with fried green tomatoes candied bacon
and a buttermilk thyme dressing that
tartness from the Green Tomato it kicks
in just as it should it's not the BLT
you were thinking about but I'll tell
you what it certainly does deliver I
will take a BLT like this anytime their
signature dish a crispy scored flounder
battered and fried with an apricot
chocolate glaze on top and that apricot
that glaze oh my God it's been on the
menu for over 30 years that is
magnificent magnificent I get why that
is Iconic do not ever take that off no
no no no no each bite flavored with the
atmosphere of the room in which it
served each room has so much character
to it whether it's you know through the
color the lighting the fireplace the
chandelier each one of them speaks to
you in its own way so the pork chop in
this room of course is the same pork
chop is in the ballroom but the ballroom
says hello to you in a little different
way than this room same food different
environment and it greets you
differently are there people that will
come and want to eat in each room oh
gosh we had some guests they came to
dine with us one night they enjoyed it
so much and they toured the home they
extended their vacation so they could
have a meal in every room in the house
of course no meal is complete without a
little dessert which at The Old Pink
House means a praline basket well listen
we're in the South so please don't be
shy all right if I've been shy so far
well maybe not maybe not yeah the basket
is filled with vanilla bean ice cream
fresh berries and mango puree along with
a touch of chocolate sauce and the
crunch from the basket the crunch from I
think that's what makes it for me
um
yeah did you like I was not offering it
to you
oh man I'm so rude you could say Just
Like Home you know you talk about it
it's a home and that is the idea behind
it that's literally how you greet people
when they come in through that front
door without a doubt without that I
think it's so important to set the tone
from that moment of hey welcome it's so
good to see you my name is Craig and
yours Kelly everyone's a guest in our
home shoot the massage all that is
Hospitality that's the goal every single
day is to show through our efforts what
you taste the staff that you encounter
the way you're treated as you wanted
throughout the home that speaks to who
we are and what we how much we value you
as one of our guests The Old Pink House
way appreciated by tourists and locals
alike with those who call Savannah home
returning a bit more often not to the
front door but to the basement the
restaurant's Tavern it's a place where
locals come first all the rooms hug you
but this one here it really puts a hug
on you when you walk in here I could
hang out here
all day and tonight
and sleep on the floor probably after
that you wouldn't be the first you
wouldn't be the first it's a very very
comfortable space in what was originally
that kitchen and laundry guests can
catch live music seven nights a week and
if you're lucky or not like all truly
proper historic Savannah spots a ghost
story or two so about four years ago one
of our guests was here and having a
great time in the tavern at this table
here okay taking photographs throughout
her meal yeah so this is what she sent
me
my God these two people are sitting
right here right that's a real person's
arm that's a person
but there's no one standing there total
chills oh my God no one's standing there
and I can't explain it
other than
it's a ghost Mr Habersham coming to
check on us the character of the House
character of the home for sure part of
being at home I guess it is it is it
started as a home so it always will be
in some way shape or form so we treat it
as such and so maybe Mr habersham's just
coming to check on his house he needs a
drink listen we got him covered we got
them covered
there's a ghost it's a ghost it's a
ghost I saw it I don't tell me otherwise
it's in that photo there is so much
character in that place I loved every
second I spent there I loved every bite
I had and I could not wait to go back
and just kick back and relax and have
more
oh it looks meanwhile we got ghosted
this morning on the BLT and the flounder
here in studio yeah
Dana
come to Savannah we'll all go excellent
it's a deal